well here for reaction Hoover Institute
senior fellow Victor Davis Hansen along
with America First legal founder Stephen
Miller and Wall Street Journal communist
Kim strassel uh Kim I want to start with
you I read your article it's brilliant
as always you're one of the best Minds
on this stuff verbalize for us how bad
this bill is
well you know Jason at least past
despicable omnibuses were only just
about spending on everything under the
Sun but this just goes to show you what
the natural and horrible limits are of
this process when people disappear into
back rooms this time they decided to
attach dozens of pieces of consequential
legislation stuff that they couldn't be
bothered to get through during the year
and stick it on here and now all of
these guys can say well we had to vote
for this bill because we had to present
a prevent a shutdown and they conduct
the question of whether or not they
would have voted for those individual
pieces of legislation big stuff like
retirement security savings changes and
the Electoral count act and public lands
management I mean where does anyone
actually stand on any individual thing
in this we don't know and they did that
by Design they're doing that by Design
because they can just come up with a
number spend a ton of money pass a bunch
of stuff and never have to take a vote
on any of it
yeah let's remember that I think it's
more than 75 percent of what we spend in
this country is mandatory programmatic
spending this is just the quote-unquote
discretionary part of the budget don't
think this is the total budget Congress
doesn't vote on the majority of the
budget but one of the things they do
have to vote on Stephen is the border
and the negligence that's happening on
the border we see it every day at least
only on Fox News you see it but when you
read and try to decipher what's in this
bill having had only hours to look at it
what's your read on what's Happening
Here
this is an unmitigated legislative
atrocity this is the worst spending bill
in our lifetimes it neuters border
security it guts immigration enforcement
it ties the hands of our border agents
and our ice officers from enforcing duly
enacted law and it does nothing to force
Biden to end Catch and Release even
though in mere days House Republicans
would take over and if given the chance
pass a provision on the spending Bill
ending Catch and Release and forcing
Biden to deport illegal aliens as we
speak right now an American Patriot Mike
Lee is fighting desperately fighting to
get border security on this bill but it
doesn't just Finance open borders it
finances critical race theory in the
form of equity and anti-racism it
finances the radical gender ideology
that is destroying the education and the
welfare of our children it finances one
radical left-wing initiative after
another in pushing Democrat priorities
into every aspect of this government and
all we would need to stop this madness
is a two-week CR a two-week short-term
bill so that Kevin McCarthy and the
House Republicans can stand up for this
country instead tonight we have the
spectacle of people waving the flag of
Ukraine while nobody in leadership in
the Senate is standing up for the United
States of America enough already
uh Victor I want to play this sound from
Senator tester from Montana there are a
lot of lame reasons to support this bill
but I want you to listen to what Senator
tester said
it also sends a tremendous signal out to
everybody in the world that we can
actually function if we would not and by
the way this isn't passed yet so I don't
want to assume it will but I think it
will if we don't pass this bill it just
sends it sends a signal of weakness to
the whole world
is that really the best reason that a
senator has for voting for this bill
that's about the lowest bar I've ever
seen as far as standards go I mean if
you do it in the middle of the night and
during the holiday season in the lame
duck congress and it's 4 000 pages that
nobody's read and you're supposed to be
proud of that that's going to send a
different message than the senator
thinks but we live in la la land an
alternate universe Jason we're 31
trillion dollars in debt and interest
rates have going up to about 4.5 on the
federal debt so just to service this
debt we're going to pay 450 billion
dollars and it's going to increase up to
a trillion at the rate we're going so
these one and a half trillion dollar
deficits are just normal now and nobody
talks about it and so there's nothing in
that bill to address physical sobriety
or the deficits and then the three big
issues that everybody was worried about
we've discussed is the Border nothing
there in fact negative uh attitudes
toward the border and then inflation and
it's going to make inflation worse and
then there's nothing about crime there's
no federal task force no federal
strategy about cartels drugs Inner City
crime nothing and then there's nothing
about energy because people can't afford
to heat their homes gas is still high
there's nothing about new federal leases
there's nothing about offshore drilling
there's nothing about animal there's
nothing about nuclear power plants so
everything that's in it is bad and
everything that's good is not in it and
it's Reckless and it's at some point
somebody's going to say my God the
country is going broke it's
unsustainable we're printing money and
we've got to do some type of radical
action but I guess they think that we
can keep borrowing for another four or
five years until we go broke
no this is this is absolutely just
ridiculous and you know what this is
done on purpose this is no accident that
they oh they suddenly get to the to the
the day before Christmas they they are
purposely doing this it was Senator
Harry Reid when he was the majority
leader in the for the Democrats in the
Senate who said oh don't worry about it
you'll never lose an election you'll
never lose an election because of some
process bill but you know what I just do
not understand how any single Republican
in the sen in the Senate could vote for
this if they are voting for this I just
have no idea how they can think they can
call themselves a conservative or a
republican what if they just wait for a
few more days they can get the calvary
coming over the hill to help on issues
like Stephen points out immigration and
others Stephen Miller Victor Davis
Hanson Kim strassel thank you so much
for joining us tonight on Hannity hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else